what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the fall of X an event you
all are loving so far and we pick up
with the dark X-Men this is awesome
right the dark X-Men comic now this
opens up with Madeleine Pryor Alex
Summers and the limbo Embassy on earth
now I'm sure those of you guys who have
not been following the X-Men have no
idea what any of that means so here's
the thing right Matalan Pryor is
basically the clone of Jean Gray from
the X-Men and because Marvel just didn't
really know what to do with her for the
last few years they stuck her in the
realm of hell right limbo whatever you
want to call it and she'd just been
ruling it for a little while now in a
story called Dark web which was really
really bad Marvel actually changed
things up so that Madeleine Pryor rules
the limbo Embassy on Earth itself and
it's been given sovereignty right so
like it's its own territory that really
is an extension of the island of krakowa
now of course Alex Summers is the
brother of cyclops his code name for the
X-Men is Havoc he's been an audigon
off-again member of the team right so
it's one of those things where he's
literally just down bad for Madeleine
Pryor if we're being honest with
ourselves and that's where things
essentially stand with their characters
now because of the fact that the limbo
Embassy is a de facto extension of the
mutination of krakowa you have a whole
bunch of protesters who were out here
and who were just kind of like telling
them to leave and and that kind of thing
but what's really cool here is that once
Madeleine Pryor arrived on Earth what
she did is she opened the embassy up to
any and all mutants of krakowa who were
basically cast offs and So for anybody
who is a seasoned X-Men reader you
picked up exactly what I did which is
okay so basically the limbo Embassy is
just a reworked version of the morlocks
in the Morlock tunnels from the old
Chris crime on X-Men Days basically yeah
that's effectively what it is it's cool
right it's a cool concept right but you
have guys like Azazel who's the father
of Nightcrawler so that's why they look
very similar and both can teleport and
so that's why you also have mutants here
that have like physical deformities
things that would prevent them from
being able to just kind of walk around
among Humanity now one of the things
that Madeleine Pryor does as she's
talking to Alex is she says what's going
on here with orcas launching this strike
against the mutant population there's no
way they wiped out 250 000 mutants at
one time because if they did they'd be
parading their corpses through the
streets or at the very least they would
be celebrating their complete and total
Annihilation the reality here is Orcas
has no idea where those mutants went any
more than Xavier does now one of the
cool things she does here is she makes
reference to genocia right when
Cassandra Nova wiped out 16 million
mutants that was nuts right like that
was really really cool but she makes
reference to that and says like I was
not technically alive right I wasn't
among the living when that whole thing
popped off so I imagine it was pretty
insane for the telepathic Community but
at the end of the day we still have a
mean to reach out and see what mutants
that exist out there are in need of our
Aid she has her own version of cerebro
right where Xavier would use the
technological version of cerebro in
order to scan the entirety of the earth
and find mutants out there that need
rescuing and that kind of thing she's
effectively doing it the same way except
she calls it the mercy crown and is kind
of its own demonic entity to a degree
now what follows next is very
reminiscent of the old Chris Claremont
Days of Future Past project Wide Awake
days from the X-Men in the 1980s and the
reason why I say that is because we pick
up with a father who gets a knock on the
door and of course when he answers the
door he ends up greeting this kid named
Benny now what ends up happening is
Benny goes downstairs into the basement
with his daughter buddy which is kind of
interesting and as a father I probably
wouldn't allow that to happen but the
thing about this is that they're kind of
down there doing their thing as far as
the dad's concerned he's not really
paying a whole bunch of attention but
what ends up going on is Benny actually
removes an inhibitor collar around on
their neck and is revealed to be Carmen
Cruz now for those of you guys who don't
know who Carmen Cruz is she's a
relatively new creation to Marvel Comics
she originally appeared in a storyline
called Children of the atom basically
she is kind of a new generation of
mutants that exist in krakowa or are
brought into krakowa kind of like a
young X-Men type team right she was even
part of Bishop's War college right if
you don't know what that means it's not
a huge deal if you do you understand
what I'm referencing so it's one of
these things where she's basically a
younger mutant out there now what she
ended up finding out is from a friend of
hers Gabe who is also part of the
children of the Adams storyline and was
actually just like a human masquerading
as a mutant if we're being honest with
ourselves uh that what he had done is he
had found a guy online who was selling
inhibitor colors now unlike old school
stories and Marvel where inhibitor
callers were designed to shut down the
powers of mutants this inhibitor collar
actually hides mutants from any Sentinel
or any device out there that can track
their location now I'm sure right off
the bat some of you guys are kind of
like I'm pretty sure I know who's
creating these inhibitor collars and we
may or may not find out my guess is
Forge if I'm a betting man like I'm
willing to bet Forge is the one who's
doing it but what's important here is
that this is an underground meeting
that's really what it is that's going on
here the issue is the father overhears
it and this is the throwback segment to
like Days of Future Past project wide
awake and that kind of thing because the
on running theme through all those
stories in the 1980s was if you see
something say something and that's
exactly what the father does he rats
Carmen out to Orcas and so literally
orcas forces come arriving onto the
scene right just full bore you know just
what looks more or less a SWAT type
system they kind of incapacitate his
daughter and then of course they go
after Carmen they ultimately overpower
her and in turn capture her and take her
away now here's the thing as this truck
is making its way through the city they
happen to drive by and on assuming man
leading against a flagpole and this
unassuming man is the person that many
of you have been asking where is this
guy
where is Gambit
here he is ladies and gentlemen and it's
not just him because
like Gambit throws his little you know
Tire busting Stars which basically Blow
The Place To Pieces right send the truck
flying not enough to destroy it but
certainly enough to incapacitate it
Archangel Warren Worthington rips open
the back door and then maggot of all
people is a part of their team as well
now here's the thing most all of you
guys know about Gambit I'm sure most of
you guys know about Archangel basically
he's a guy with metal Wings it's really
all he is now and he has a healing
Factor right he has a whole huge history
in Marvel Comics which we're not going
to go into here and maggot is like the
weirdest X-Man that you've never heard
of this guy these maggots that are on
him that's how he eats
right like they help him to kind of
maintain his existing power but like
they feed on energy from like anything
and then give it to him so you're gonna
you're gonna see him put those things to
use here in a minute and honestly it's
gonna be every bit as gruesome as you
think it's gonna be but what ends up
happening of course is they remove a
proper inhibitor collar that was put on
Carmen which is to say the ability to
shut down her powers and of course what
you end up getting is one of these guys
one of these orcas agents who's still
awake and starts kicking this kind of
soldier who's there telling him to wake
up at the same time he sent out an SOS
calling for reinforcements and so what
ends up happening when this agent
manifests it's a robot version of
Wolverine specifically it's Albert now
if you guys remember the old Iron Man
2020 story that we covered eons ago
Albert is a robot version of Wolverine
that's been around for a very long time
he was actually created by a guy named
Donald Pierce way back in the day it was
funny because it was Albert and LCD
basically LCD was like a little girl who
was a robot that had a self-destruct
protocol she ended up becoming super
smart over Road her programming and then
her and Albert basically escaped and
then struck out into the world on their
own but that's why he keeps saying Elsie
that's why he keeps saying that name
because she was basically his partner I
felt like that was a cool little bit of
history and something to be aware of but
this guy is quote unquote following his
program now of course he's also a little
broken at the same time he also appeared
relatively recently in the Wolverine
story and was presumably just kind of
left defunct out there in the world in
majipor they ultimately ended up
discovering him and of course orcas is
trying to work with him but with like
minimal effort right they're just kind
of using him as a Mindless robot out
there he's cool Albert is definitely
going to have a bigger role to play and
the entirety of this whole fall of X
event but what ends up happening is that
in the midst of all this with like
Sentinels showing up helicopters showing
up reinforcements arriving honestly the
days of Gambit and his forces are
effectively numbered right they're just
in underground resistance team that's
when azazo pops it on the scene grabs
some guys and teleports them away and
that's when Madeleine Pryor makes her
presence known Now understand for
someone like Gambit he knows exactly who
Madeleine Pryor is like Carmen Cruz kind
of understands to a degree but she
doesn't know how deep the rabbit hole
goes when it comes to Madeleine Pryor
and so that's why Gambit tells her like
when she asks are they on our side the
response of Gambit is it's complicated
right because with characters like
implets and havoc and Azazel and
Madeleine Pryor operating as an X-Men
team it can't be anything but just some
reworked version of Magneto's
Brotherhood of evil mutants and in fact
to a degree it is because when Madeleine
Pryor's X-Men show up here they start
killing everybody and they do it with no
concern or reservation every member of
orcas is killed like you literally have
guys who are being cut in half Warren
Worthington was actually stabbed by
Albert so like he's injured I mean he
has a healing factor and he'll recover
but like Madeleine Pryor turns a car
into a demonic entity which starts
consuming a guy and so she literally
tells them no mercy my X-Men kill
everybody now the kicker about all this
is that Albert stabs Havoc through the
neck right he kills Alex Summers on the
spot now is it a very unceremonious
death of one of the longest standing
mutants in Marvel Comics yeah but if
this tells you anything it should be
that we will likely end up seeing Havoc
return in some form or fashion in Marvel
right I mean literally they're dragging
his corpse he's just kind of bleeding
out of the neck and hopefully Madeleine
Pryor can do something to keep him alive
although things look pretty bleak right
for this guy and so what's cool here is
that you have Madeleine who's just like
okay look we're done right like we're
basically finished here I mean it makes
sense given like what's going on right
because this whole entire conflict with
like the dark X-Men fighting this is
happening in a matter like probably
within less than a minute right it's
like how fast all this stuff is
happening like giant Sentinel showing up
and stuff like that you got to get out
of there as fast as you possibly can
because these things have been designed
to eradicate mutants and while Madeleine
Pryor is not the most well-versed when
it comes to like facing off against
Sentinels guys like Gambit and all those
folks even maggot whose literal maggot
is eating an actual guy at that moment
even he's smart enough to realize we
have to get out of here because these
Sentinels exist to do nothing but
eradicate mutants that's it and they
will destroy us without an ounce of
remorse so ultimately Madeleine Pryor
tells Azazel we have to get out of here
the issue is Warren Worthington is Left
Behind that literally Madeleine Pryor is
just kind of like there's nothing we can
do and so what you end up doing is
picking up with Archangel at an
undisclosed orcas black site and he's
kind of brought in for what seems to be
a sort of experiment and now what goes
on is we end up finding out that orcas
at this site has what's being referred
to as the one true Goblin Queen now I'm
not gonna lie to you guys I have no
earthly clue who this is unless Marvel
is somehow shifting things up and saying
that Madeleine Pryor is not the actual
Madeline Pryor that we know this is the
real Madeline Pryor and she's been crazy
and in hell and demonic Force this
entire time that seems to be what's
going on the only other alternative here
is that what orcas is doing is they're
mutating and restructuring mutants and
this particular instance that thing
that's standing behind her the feet look
remarkably close to Nightcrawler so I
don't know exactly what it is that orcas
is doing but it looks like they're
creating their own kind of warped and
twisted mutant versions very similar to
what we saw Sinister doing in the sins
of sinister event but with that being
said guys if you want to get caught up
on fall of X make sure you click this
link to our playlist and I will catch
you all later
peace